les petits plats dans les grands pour le
badminton réunionnais au stade de l'est
mais à 6e édition du tournoi
international de badminton prend de
l'ampleur avec l'aide du conseil
départemental
tout a commencé par la présentation des
joueurs internationaux numéro de rue ce
numéro accro à trois champions de france
et un vice-champion d'europe
rien que ça j'ai une bonne expérience
l'année dernière parce que j'avais j'ai
déjà pratiqué le tournoi l'année
dernière j'ai apprécié beaucoup de
choses et bien sûr après mon titre j'ai
posé la question aussi et j'aurai la
chance d'être si j'avais la chance
d'être réinvité donc j'ai attendu avec
impatience la réponse ici c'est
différent déjà il ya l'aspect de la
langue
donc c'est vraiment très facile d'aller
vers les personnes et qui viennent vers
nous cette année je suis obligé de dire
c'est beaucoup plus impressionnant parce
que le génial il est différent de
l'année dernière donc ça fait vraiment
comme si c'était un point international
quelque chose de vraiment structure
hêtre
après la visite de l'espace naturel
sensible de la roche écrite de la
plongée peu de plages
les matchs d'exhibition permis de jauger
le haut niveau
en fait ils sont quasiment tous ses
joueurs professionnels donc ils font à
l'entraînement quasiment toute la
semaine je sais pas quelle fréquence
mais voilà c'est sûr que à la réunion
ici on n'a pas forcément le temps avec
le travail je travaille en tant
qu'entraîneur que j'entraîne plus les
joueurs que je m'entraîne moi même donc
un moment donné sa joie sursaut sur le
match pour nous ça rapporte rien après
sa femme aussi un peu développé le
badminton ici sur l'île
parce que nous on nous a tous beaucoup
cherchent beaucoup comme ça dans le
partage et voilà on est on est
partenaires solibad on essaie de
développer un peu grâce à notre sport
parce que nous ont vite ça et on
aimerait bien que je plus de personnes
puissent puisse faire la même chose que
nous enfin le wellington c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut voir en direct ce cas
la télé on se rend pas du tout content
du niveau de la vitesse du volant et
c'est vrai que la plupart des gens dès
qu'ils le voyant vrai sont vraiment
impressionné de la vitesse et aussi du
fin de nos réflexes les mouvements qu'on
fait c'est vrai que c'est assez ludique
et attractif qu à mon avis ils viennent
me voir en vitesse réelle parce qu'à la
télé c'est pas forcément ça reflète pas
forcément la vitesse en condition réelle
sur le terrain donc à mon avis s'il faut
venir voir le badminton c'est c'est dans
cette période là c'est au type qu'il
faut venir pour vraiment voir ce que
c'est que le vrai badminton devraient
être bannies talent de compétition et
surtout le haut niveau 280 joueurs et
plus de 600 matches dans un stade de
l'est
habillés pour l'occasion le badminton à
sa vitrine internationale
je crois que c'est le rêve de tout
sportif de pouvoir jouer dans une salle
comme ça avec un aménagement de telle
sorte je crois que
quand on manque se référa quand même ça
allait si bien aménagé ça nous donne des
ailes aussi ont envie de se transcender
donc on va voir des beaux matches de
demain c'est sûr quand on va vers l'est
vers l'est et vers l'asie chine suspend
numéro 1 malaisie c'est d'être pendu
méreau un mois j'ai participé un j'ai eu
la chance de participer à la championne
du monde par équipe en malaisie quand on
part à la salle on avec les bus
on équipe et enfin il ya des motards
devant derrière qui poussent des
voitures pour enfants puissent passer
parce que ils n'ont pas le temps quoi le
benton ces numéros un et que c'est comme
ça que les autres ils ont affaire place
pour les joueurs et le jeu en vaut la
chandelle sport national dans la plupart
des pays asiatiques disciplines
pratiquées dans tout l'océan indien
si demain à ce type est labellisé sur le
circuit mondial la réunion deviendrait
une étape sur le chemin olympique